I I do remember when we were when we  were writing the episode of Breaking the  episode talking about what we wanted  those guns to look like and and we very  specifically you and I had the same  image I I you know all of us did when  you say Blunderbuss yeah  based on that were fun  where the barrel at the end goes like  yeah we write that in and we and we call  it a blunderbuss yeah we've written that  and on the day we get we get these guns  they look like actual rifles and we're  like well this is this ain't fun  this is what they actually used in 1776  yeah oh yeah I don't [ __ ] care we  don't give a [ __ ] bring us what we wrote  in the script and they're like [ __ ]  this is what you wrote in the script and  we're like well don't bring us what we  were thinking  didn't we determine that there were no  actual guns made with quite the  dimensions that Eleanor  [Music]